Speaker 1: FOX News hosts and guests flipping
their lids as the red wave collapsed. Crumbled.
It was like, you know, when you put cotton
candy in water and it just disappears. That
was the the red wave disappearing last night.
Check out some of these clips, starting with
Fox News pundit Marc Thiessen saying this
is a disaster for the republican party.
Speaker 2: Let's think about this. We welcome
back mahtesian and helpful jr to the panel.
We talked a lot about debates and when some
candidates did debates and some didn't do them
had the October 25th debate and September
30th, would this race have changed? Mark?
Speaker 3: I think it might have or maybe it
wouldn't have. I mean, I think there's a broader
issue here, which is that so think about this.
We have the worst inflation in four decades,
the worst collapse in real wages in 40 years, the
worst crime wave since the 1990s, the worst border
crisis in US history. We have Joe Biden, who is
the least popular president since Harry Truman.
Speaker 1: So now none of this stuff
is true, and I'll prove it in a moment.
Speaker 3: Presidential polling happened
and there wasn't a red wave. That is a
searing indictment of the Republican Party.
Speaker 1: All right. So a lot a lot a lot
of admitting there that this is a disaster.
Brian KILMEADE with a similar perspective,
repeating many of the same lies shifted.
Speaker 2: And right now, Zeldin is probably
within five points. It might be out of reach for
them. There's no Biden concession there. You see,
there's some unhappiness. But I don't
know about you guys. I'm shocked. It was
a no red wave. If you think about
inflation, a 40 year high crime,
the worst since the 1980s, the unpopular
president with an agenda that's more
green oriented than people oriented. Yeah.
Speaker 1: They are telling you all lies.
Okay. Yes, they are correctly pointing out the
red wave failed. Credit to them for pointing
that out. But let's fact check this. I love
it. Worst inflation in four decades, they say
reality. It's the worst inflation since 1989. It's
33 years. It did hit pieces of four decades. Maybe
we give them a pass on that one. But check out
some of these other ones. Worst collapse in real
wages in 40 years. That would take us to 1982.
That is very clearly not true. Median inflation
adjusted, that's what they mean by real inflation
adjusted wages. That is not a chart that suggests
now wages are at their lowest point in 40 years.
In fact, it is very much the opposite. Very,
very much the opposite. We're at a peak, not at
the bottom. They are liars. They said worse crime
since the 1990s or the 1980s even. That's also
not true. Here is the crime rate since the 1990s
and as you can see, it has actually declined
over that period of time. It has declined even
if you look specifically, as we will do now at
murder homicide. Those rates have also declined,
although they have very recently ticked up a hair.
But overall, it is part of a downward trend. Worst
border crisis in history, they say. Well, I don't
know how you measure that. Is it the number of
people you catch or that you don't catch? It
is true that arrests at the border are up.
But that means we're catching people. That means
they're not getting in here. How is that a crisis?
And importantly, nothing really has changed under
Biden since Donald Trump at the border. And then
lastly, they said Biden, the least popular
president since Truman. That's not true. Joe
Biden right now is about as popular as Trump
was at this point in his presidency. About as
popular as Ronald Reagan was at this point in his
presidency, within a point or two of Barack Obama
and Clinton's popularity at this point in their
presidencies. And by the way, were it not for 911,
which buoyed George W Bush's approval rating,
Biden would be doing better than George W Bush
as well. The reason Bush ended up with temporarily
a higher approval was 911. Okay. Every claim is a
lie. They are furious. Maybe look at reality.
Historically low unemployment, stock market,
GDP, all the indicators we talk about. And then
maybe they would be a little bit less shocked.